Mobile Task Force Edna-84, also known by the
code name “And Thus Upon His Crucible”,
is on one of the strangest missions they’ve
ever been sent on.
They sit in a darkened room, beads of sweat
trickling down their brows.
The lights of computer monitors shine up into
their faces.
They’re tackling a monster that, if it escapes,
will literally devour all of creation.
It has no fear, it has no remorse, and if
it isn’t kept contained by Edna-84, it may
escape and wreak havoc across the world.
Oh, and did we mention it’s trapped inside
a Minecraft server?
You heard us right: SCP-4335 is a cognitohazardous,
extradimensional being of pure terror, trapped
inside a procedurally generated world in the
immensely popular game Minecraft.
You hear about a lot of horrifying monsters
being described as Lovecraftian, but only
this monster is Minecraftian.
There’s a lot that needs explaining here,
and we intend to get to all of it, but let’s
start with how the Foundation keeps this truly
exceptional beast contained.
The Foundation first discovered SCP-4335 back
in 2010, shortly after the Alpha Version of
Minecraft was released.
Because of the online nature of the game,
it’s proven to be impossible to contain
4335 externally, seeing as it isn’t confined
to any one physical location.
Shutting off the server 4335 is found in is
not an effective containment method either,
as this just causes the entity to simply hop
to a different server.
The Foundation’s greatest fear is that 4335
will one day make the leap out of Minecraft
and cause chaos in our world.
That’s why it’s imperative to draft Containment
Procedures for SCP-4335 within the game.
This led to the creation of a containment
site unlike any other: Site-M1, the first
official Foundation Site made entirely out
of Minecraft blocks.
Everyone who was originally involved in the
server has been removed and amnesthetized.
Since then, elite SCP Foundation Containment
Specialists and Gamers have been constructing
the perfect prison for SCP-4335.
Site-M1 is a large, stone complex built into
the side of a mountain.
It has a number of key features - including
a supply area filled with materials vital
for 4335’s continued containment.
Chests filled with books that contain SCP-4335's
containment procedures.
A few animal farms, for the purpose of breeding
and killing livestock for their meat.
The entrance to a mine.
Several chests containing books specifically
designed for civilians to learn about 4335,
if they ever breach containment and enter
the server.
And of course, the actual containment chamber
for SCP-4335 itself, which is a little more
complicated.
4335’s containment chamber is built out
of several layers, all made from iron blocks.
The outermost cube is 75 x 75 x 75 blocks,
the inner cube is 55 x 55 x 55 blocks, and
the innermost cube is 25 x 25 x 25 blocks,
creating several levels of defense.
Finally one layer within all these others,
which contains the anomaly proper, is made
from obsidian blocks.
SCP-4335 is bound into the center of the containment
chamber with a complex mechanism.
The outermost cube is completely filled with
water, and several dispensers capable of rapidly
dispensing large amounts of items in a short
amount of time line the cube.
The cube also contains several mob farms,
which are devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when they
die.
The chamber is essentially designed to funnel
a constant flow of items inwards to SCP-4335.
There are even contingency measures for if
SCP-4335 manages to breach containment.
If escape is attempted, blocks of TNT detonate
above the ceiling, causing lava to pour into
the chamber.
At that point, MTF Edna-84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into its
containment chamber.
To do this, they use a mix of fire-resistance
potions and Ender Pearls - which have teleportation
capabilities.
Interestingly, there’s one more basic method
of luring SCP-4335 back into the obsidian
cube: Taunting and insulting.
One of SCP-4335’s many anomalous abilities
is being able to hear people through the screen,
and - being a proud creature - it often responds
to insults by charging in to directly engage
the insulter.
If SCP-4335 still manages to breach the containment
that has been set up for it, then they expect
that it will likely soon hop into another
server.
At that point, the goal will shift to finding
the monster and recontaining it.
With Containment Procedures this complex and
extensive, it shouldn’t come as a surprise
that SCP-4335 rests firmly in the Keter Class.
What exactly is this anomalous entity?
Why does its containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items?
And how did it end up in Mojang’s popular
building and survival game in the first place?
SCP-4335, in terms of physical dimensions,
appears almost identical to the player character,
with an all-black skin.
It also appears to be constantly shrouded
in a cloud of smoke particles, and has long,
black tendrils protruding from its back.
In some respects, 4335 has been compared to
two popular creepypasta figures: Herobrine
and The Slenderman.
But 4335 is far stranger.
Its physical body behaves similarly to most
assets native to the game, with a few peculiar
anomalous abilities we’ll discuss soon.
Handling SCP-4335 is an extremely delicate
process.
If command blocks, creative mode, or server
commands are ever enabled in a server with
SCP-4335, the server will instantly shut down,
and SCP-4335 will move to a different server.
SCP-4335 also uses its tendrils to destroy
surrounding blocks before consuming them.
With each successful consumption, SCP-4335
grows, and when it reaches sufficient size,
it hops to a different server.
As you can see, keeping SCP-4335 contained
is an uphill battle, but luckily there are
two factors on the Foundation’s side here.
The first is that SCP-4335 is immobilized
while consuming items and blocks, limiting
its ability to actively escape Foundation
forces.
The second factor is that SCP-4335 needs a
rest period between consuming blocks in order
to grow, meaning, if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn’t able to grow.
These two factors have informed the entirety
of the Foundation’s Containment Procedures
around SCP-4335: It’s locked into its chamber
and fed items and blocks constantly, effectively
rooting it in place.
When SCP-4335 begins to grow, the Foundation
also found that the application of Ender Pearls
helps reduce it back to its normal size.
However, SCP-4335 does have a method of striking
back against its captors.
4335 is Vurgent-class multi-sensory cognitohazard.
Anyone viewing it without proper training
and protection may experience distressing
hallucinations.
SCP-4335 is also capable of telepathic speech
with people playing on its server, and - as
we alluded to earlier - it can also hear any
noises you make while playing.
“Weird” is a term thrown around a lot
when it comes to SCPs, considering it’s
pretty much a requirement for the Foundation
to take interest in you.
But an all-devouring Minecraft demon that
can hear you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards.
MTF Edna-84 first discovered SCP-4335 in the
single-player server of Minecraft user Leakingheart.
Three team members - Jason Yelsan, Richard
Duchamp, and Sheila Freemason - covertly entered
the game to investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature.
When Leakingheart first discovered their presence
on what he thought was a private server, he
quickly left, a little creeped out by the
sudden intrusion.
Thankfully, the trio was still able to locate
SCP-4335.
They discovered the creature hiding inside
a giant crater, as though it had impacted
the earth at considerable speed.
Richard Duchamp, who was the leader of the
team at the time, made the mistake of looking
directly at the entity.
In that moment, he experienced the full force
of SCP-4335’s cognitohazardous effects.
He hallucinated, believing that his keyboard
was melting before his eyes.
In the aftermath of this incident, Duchamp
was taken off the case, and Jason Yelsan was
promoted to head of the project.
Things were still going to get stranger.
Yelsan was able to open a dialogue with the
creature after containing it in a chamber
filled with lava.
It asked him whether it had landed in the
right location - meaning, our world - and
Yelsan informed it that it’d somehow fallen
into the world of Minecraft instead.
The creature was at first confused, and then
angry and resentful about its situation.
It vowed to find its way into our world somehow,
and obtain more “sustenance.”
A few months after this, the entity managed
to breach containment and hop into another
server.
Yelsan and two others once again managed to
track it down and recontain it, but this time,
two civilians also inhabiting the server were
exposed to the anomalous effects of SCP-4335.
They weren’t hurt, but they did appear strange
and incoherent after experiencing 4335’s
cognitohazards.
The Foundation tracked them down in the aftermath
and gave them amnestic treatment.
4335 was contained shortly thereafter.
Once again, Yelsan came face to face with
his new foe.
Eight months after being captured, 4335 granted
Yelsan another interview from containment.
4335 admitted that it almost respected Yelsan
and the rest of the Foundation for figuring
out how to capture and contain it so quickly.
In exchange, it would give the Foundation
something extremely valuable: Information.
First, it asked one question of Yelsan: How
does he define “creation?”
Yelsan replied, “Uh… something that is
built and brought to this universe by a sapient
being, using other things from this universe?”
4335 agreed.
It went on to explain that it came from a
universe devoid of creation.
A dark and unknowable place, filled with nothing
but violent, random chaos.
Its dimension existed directly above ours,
and it often looked down at us through a dimensional
window, fascinated by all the creation below.
It plotted and dreamed to one day infiltrate
our reality, and Yelsan finally had the opportunity
to ask the magic question, “Why?”
Though he wasn’t quite ready for the brutal
honesty of SCP-4335’s reply.
“I do not like to lie, so I will tell you
now.
I wish to suck it dry of the toys of whatever
force controls your universe.
Destroy the light, destroy the Earth, and
destroy humanity.
It reminded me… of me.
A blubbering mass of intelligence and order.
It sickens me in ways I cannot comprehend.
I hope you understand.”
SCP-4335 was a connoisseur of creation, and
it sought to devour all of it.
In this moment, Yelsan realized what an incredibly
dangerous entity he was dealing with.
The only mystery was why this creature had
somehow landed in Minecraft instead of our
world, which appeared to be the only thing
that saved us.
But Yelsan didn’t have time to think: 4335
was about to stage another daring escape attempt.
One of its tendrils reached out and attacked
Yelsan’s player character.
In that moment, the real life Yelsan began
to hallucinate and panic.
Suddenly, back in the game, a series of abnormally
tall, slender black figures appeared and began
deconstructing the containment chamber around
SCP-4335.
It had somehow summoned new minions into the
game to assist in this containment breach.
Jason Yelsan entered cognitohazard quarantine
following this incident, and was removed from
the project.
And he wasn’t the only one affected by this
incident.
Following the first appearance of these long,
dark figures, players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their own
games.
The Foundation managed to find a solution:
They contacted Mojang and had the creatures
patched into the game during the next update,
as a new non-anomalous entity, which seemed
to stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools.
They’re now known as the Endermen, and are
beloved among fans for being one of the creepier
enemies.
To this day, containment efforts continue
for SCP-4335.
There’s only one question left: Why did
the entity fall into Minecraft rather than
our world?
The file posits the most likely answer.
Because 4335 defines creation as elements
made by sapient beings.
In Minecraft, the most popular game in the
world at the height of 4335’s power, everything
that exists is the product of code made by
humans.
Creation is truly abundant there.
As for our world, in SCP-4335’s extra-dimensional
eyes, there is no creation, no intelligent
design, no soothing piano soundtrack.
Just frightening, chaotic, randomness, which
is too unlike its own dimension.
So even if SCP-4335 ever did arrive in our
reality, it would likely be disappointed by
how little there is to eat.
Now check out “SCP-3082 - Neverland’s
Lost Boys and Girls” and “SCP-3008 - Trapped
In Ikea” for more fascinating and strange
locations from the world of the SCP Foundation!